tout a basculé en un jour dans sa lutte
contre le kobe 19 la france suspend
provisoirement l'utilisation du vaccin
astrazeneca dimanche
en réponse à l'affolement européen le
premier ministre jean castex avait
déclaré toute sa confiance envers le
vaccin anglo-suédois mais 24 heures plus
tard emmanuel macron a sifflé la fin de
la récréation
l'autorité européenne ema rendra demain
après midi un avis sur le recours à ce
vaccin est donc sur la recommandation du
ministre des solidarités de la santé la
décision qui a été prise en conformité
aussi avec notre politique européenne
c'est de suspendre par précaution la
vaccination avec astrazeneca en espérant
la reprendre vite si la vie de l'om a le
permet ce revirement de situation
hexagonale intervient après une journée
encore marquée par des événements
majeurs aux alentours de midi les
pompiers des bouches du rhône ont
annoncé suspendre l'administration
d'astrazeneca à leur personnel après
l'apparition d'effets indésirables des
effets qui semble impliquer un trouble
de la coagulation depuis plus d'un mois
30 cas de caillots de sang ont été
détectés en europe sur les cinq millions
de patients vaccinés ce lundi en milieu
d'après midi
c'est l'allemagne qui a décidé à son
tour de suspendre provisoirement
l'utilisation du vaccin d'astrazeneca
par précaution suivi dans la foulée par
la france l'italie l'espagne et le
portugal
en parallèle pas folle qui lave ses
alertes ont surgi et tout en attendant
une analyse détaillée et rigoureuse de
lagence pharmaceutique et en suivant
toujours le principe de précaution qui
guide toutes nos actions nous avons
décidé de suspendre temporairement les
administrations au moins dans les
semaines à venir afin que le m&a pendant
le laps de temps qu'elle demande pour
évaluer soigneusement ses cadres et pour
que les agences nationales du médicament
donne de réponses à ces signaux
nationale était mêlée quand même toit au
fleix génial la liste des pays européens
à suspendre astrazeneca continue de
s'allonger dans le sillage du danemark
pro
et pays a stoppé l'administration du
vaccin le 11 mars la bulgarie l'islande
l'irlande ou encore les pays-bas en ont
fait de même
d'autres pays comme l'autriche ou la
roumanie ont décidé de retirer un lot de
leurs circuits de vaccination un appel
en chaîne qui a poussé l'organisation
mondiale de la santé un appel au calme
depuis notre dernière conférence de
presse vendredi
plusieurs autres pays ont suspendu
l'utilisation des vaccins astrazeneca
par mesure de précaution après que des
caillots sanguins ont été signalés chez
des personnes ayant reçu le vaccin de
deux lots produits en europe
cela ne signifie pas nécessairement que
ces événements sont liés à la
vaccination pour l'om est l'utilisation
du vaccin astrazeneca est encore valable
des recommandations à ce stade et que
les avantages de la vaccination avec le
vaccin d'astrazeneca et d'autres vaccins
l'emportent sur le risque d'infection
par le coville dont nous savons qu'il ya
un impact significatif avec des
personnes victimes de maladies graves et
d'hospitalisations voire de décès
l'organisation mondiale de la santé doit
tenir une conférence de presse mardi
après midi pour donner plus
d'indications sur le vaccin
anglo-suédois et ses effets indésirables
l' agence européenne des médicaments
prévoit quand elle une réunion
extraordinaire ce jeudi après avoir
autorisé astrazeneca sur le marché le 29
janvier dernier